Oh what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very pumped to be talking about how to
get ahead career and professional
development expert is joining us today
Zak slay back hello Alan thanks for
having me very pumped to have you on the
show we have so much to talk about
regarding social capital regarding
knowing how to get to people tomorrow
with these communications and advance
our careers for those that don't know
Zak's background his epic he's a career
expert writer and venture capital
professional he's the author of how to
get ahead coming soon from mcgraw-hill
and he writes that Zacks laid-back calm
that links in the bio about how to
succeed in your career as an ambitious
young professional
he's also principal at 15:17 fund a
venture capital firm backed by Peter
Thiel investing in startups led by
college-aged founders and you can
download his twelve done-for-you email
scripts to help you confidently reach
any busy person tomorrow and that link
is below and those are very powerful
they're very succinct they get to the
point they have this really strong
genuine sincere aspect to them which I
love so much and that's one of the
reasons why we've been able to amass the
social capital that we've have on the
show as well so Zak let's talk on the on
the big picture about the state of
humanity what are your thoughts about it
well it's interesting that you asked me
this question today because I remember
tweeting out this morning seeing the
video of the Falcon Heavy boosters
landing the second time and thinking to
myself okay this is the second time it's
happened the first time was a big deal
and like gave me goosebumps when I
watched it I it was amazing but the
second time it's not really a big deal
and we're going to get to the point
quickly we're watching rocket boosters
land up right which is weird right like
that should freak people out that that's
happening it's just gonna become anodyne
and assume gung ho hum and it's just
something that we see all the time so
I think it's really easy to get
pessimistic about the state of humanity
to look at everything that's wrong and
want to go ahead and fix it but I am
actually pretty optimistic we've made
probably more significant leaps in the
last couple of years than the last two
decades and I'm pretty optimistic about
the future I'm glad to be alive today
yeah likewise the rebase lining
ourselves to reusable rocket boosters
it's very interesting just reducing the
cost of getting a kilogram of anything
into space yeah that much is so
important to actually being able to do
anything in space yeah so the reason the
reusable rocket boosters are really
really exciting yeah yeah it's a
beautiful time to be alive it's also one
of the most complex times to be alive
eight billion humans exponential
technology solving some of these
pressing challenges what about your
thoughts on the on the population size
as well as the exponential technologies
yeah I think that that's one of these
things that it's consistently throughout
history problematic because we don't
know what the next thing is going to do
what the next crisis is going to look
like what the next technology will
provide for us but I'm this kind of
sounds like indefinite optimism the idea
from zero on a few familiar yeah and I'm
not a fan of indefinite optimism but I'm
pretty confident in our ability to solve
these problems going forward right no I
I think that for the most part in
national politics is a bit of a
distraction but you saw recently a lot
of people making fun of a certain
Congress person for saying that we need
new technologies that haven't been
invented yet to solve problems like
climate change right and like yeah the
statement wasn't made in the most
eloquent way but the point that that
Congress person was trying to get at it
is one that we're actually very very
good at finding solutions to pressing
problems right I remember being asked a
question way back when I was actually in
high school at an economics seminar that
I was attending because I was a weird
high school student who attended
economic seminars and the question was
when will we run out of the last
Olive Oyl right and it's a trick
question because the answer is never
right
the last barrel of oil will become
exponentially more expensive and when it
gets that point that it's ridiculously
insanely expensive that incentivizes
entrepreneurs to enter the market and
solve the energy problem right it's this
classic supply and demand yep supply
drops down to extremely low left of oil
and if the man stays consistent quantity
demanded stays consistent and the price
is just gonna go up but then that also
means the incentive for finding a
solution goes up correct yeah correct
and that's when we when our energy
consumption continues to increase and
the our ability to take something like a
of nuclear fusion solar energy things
that have close to as close to as zero
in net environmental effect versus a
negative environmental effect maybe even
a positive some environmental effect
carbon sequestration things like that
are very exciting I agree with you
Millennials and Gen Z and even younger
will be tackling lots of these pressing
challenges there's a very strong
optimism with that Zach I want to know
about this journey I loved learning
about your work at praxis leading up to
it was University of Penn mmm-hmm and
then I was University of Minnesota and
then we both did you drop out after
sophomore year I went on leave after
sophomore year and I according to the
University I'm just on indefinitely yeah
and then so then you go into practice
where you were identifying really
powerful young entrepreneurs and linking
them up with really powerful high tech
startups and then training their skill
sets in business development that was
three and a half years of your of your
work there and then that led you to this
you know the 15 seventeenth on the how
to get ahead so yeah tell us about this
is this a journey of themselves yeah I
was fortunate through this high school
economics seminar I actually mentioned
earlier to meet somebody who became a
mentor to me and I stayed in touch with
this person he went off and eventually
founded prax's Isaac Morehouse and I
joined him while he was building that up
the director of business development and
that was a whirlwind experience because
for what that company does it takes this
entrepreneurial young talent places it
at a start-up trains it in like business
skills like marketing business
development sales it my role was a lot
of career coaching sales and business
development and recruiting all at the
same time yeah I learned a lot very
quickly I largely learned that the vast
majority of what young people are taught
about their careers by guidance
counsellors or career experts that are
writing books that are just republished
every single year with minimal updates
is wrong a lot of what's being taught to
people about how to get started in their
careers and how to make the transition
to the next step of their careers is
just wrong it's largely coming from
people who haven't had to find a job
since before the Great Recession many of
whom haven't had to find a job since
before the internet was invented I'm
just pretty scary when you start
thinking about it and it ends up hurting
people who are ambitious trying to get
ahead trying to start out their careers
and they're turning to the resources
that they've trusted thus far through
the school system and they're coming up
short yeah so after a couple of years
doing that three and a half years I
eventually started writing more
seriously about succeeding in your
career and then more recently join the
team over at 15:17 Fund where we're more
supporting the founder side of things
but good chunk of my time is spent on
helping our portfolio companies identify
and recruit really outstanding talent
yeah and there's this very very
fascinating way of perceiving young
people where they're rather than
thinking about them potentially getting
crushed by the collegiate / political
economic social machinery there's this
other aspect of it which is they can do
the self learning via YouTube Khan
Academy's all these types of things all
of a sudden you're getting these
synthetic biology experts or you're
getting these you're getting these young
artificial intelligence experts brain
computer interface kids that are 16 Ori
starting to tweak with it so this is the
type of stuff that startups love they
love
young kids that are self motivated
learners that haven't been crushed by
the economic machinery yet of needing to
fit inside of a square hole as a circle
that type of thing so this has also been
one of the one of the things that you
know you're writing about with how to
get ahead so I want you to teach us we
have you know we have these assets as
well this is the you know the cover of
of the book and one of the things a
proven six step system to unleash your
personal brand and build a world-class
network so opportunities come to you and
let's talk about this opportunity
machine we'll talk about yeah this is
the opportunity machine one of the
centrioles thesis is of the book it's
the central concept of the book the book
is broken down into six chapters each of
which is represented as a step inside
what I call the opportunity machine and
I called that because I think you can
think of your career like a system you
can think of your career like a machine
if you set it up and you do the
maintenance it works right and each step
of that opportunity machine is something
that you can do time and time again no
matter where you are in your career
let's pull that one up it's the next one
Ronnie and then you can start with the
top with focus yeah and then run us
through him yeah I I start with focus
which really means how do you set
effective meaningful goals right I think
particularly for ambitious smart young
people were always got like good grades
when they were in school they've never
actually learned how to set goals
outside of school right and most
goal-setting exercises that you find in
a lot of self-help books in particular
are terrible there are things just like
identify everything you want it's like
that's not helpful what people need
would people need to really feel
motivated at work in their careers is to
see themselves progressing towards the
achievement of meaningful goals yes
every word in that sentence is important
Jessica's and after you focus on where
do you want to bring yourself what's the
next step of your career what do you
want to see yourself doing I like to
think in terms of one to three years
look any further off is kind of hard to
identify anything sooner is too soon to
be really ambitious then
to humble yourself and learn from people
who know more than you that's right this
is the unique advantage that people have
when they're starting their careers and
when they're making a transition to new
stage their career because when you're
starting something new in your career
your time isn't worth anything it's it's
really it's like this is why people tell
insurance to go get coffee write a good
internship hopefully you're not actually
just getting coffee but you don't really
have that much in terms of skills you
don't really have that much in terms of
knowledge so you have to learn from
people who know more than you identify
three types of people I call them
teachers / coaches consultants mentors
these are the people you work directly
with and advisors these are people you
might meet once twice maybe a couple
times a year
and you ask them specific questions to
try to learn specific kinds of knowledge
from them then you actually want to go
out and you want to create evidence of
what you can do right yeah
evidence of what you've learned evidence
of your newfound skills so that's
execution and then once you've done that
you want to signal so going back to an
interesting point you made about there's
all this knowledge out there there's all
these ways to access knowledge out there
Khan Academy Coursera YouTube all these
different MOOCs all these different
programs but at the end of the day if
you go to a college campus and you ask I
know I've done this is a fun experiment
to do this is something I've learned
from Isaac go to a college campus and in
a room of 100 students ask them this
question how many of you would choose to
be here if you were paying the money
you're paying learning what you're
learning getting to do what you're doing
but you don't get a credential at the
end of the day in a room of a hundred
students and I've done this on maybe a
dozen campuses now in a room of 100
students to may raise their hands to
which I tell them great you should be a
professor because this is an
apprenticeship system for professors
everyone else there is trying to buy a
credential which signals something about
them into the world but it's a pretty
weak signal so this is why a personal
brand actually plays an important part
in the book I
at first bristled that phrase personal
brand because folks the wrong images
books images if someone standing in
front of their rented Ferrari in their
garage right on YouTube but really your
personal brand is this is your distilled
reputation yeah
like the fact that somebody was able to
refer me to you for example is my
personal brand working for me that's
right right
so I talked about a couple different
ways you can craft this brand how you
get the right people to identify with
your brand how you can actually build
tools to allow you to identify and keep
those people's contacts then you
actually want to actively go out and do
the business development side of it
which is connecting this is networking
right and networking isn't going to
networking events I hate network most
networking events if you go to them you
just run into people who are at the same
stage in their career as you we can talk
about that a little bit and then you
actually have to pitch yourself for new
opportunities which get you to the stage
you can start all over again and get to
the next stage in your career mm-hmm-hmm
and then the cycle happens again when
you level up yep then you keep going and
level up again and keep going so let's
break this down one more time with some
added commentary so I love the idea of
having a goal this has been now this is
over and over again being preached that
you have to have some sort of a
meaningful drive that you have in your
life and then that's what this 1 to 3
year time frame that you speak of like
where do you want to see yourself what
do you want to be doing
that'll maximize you you waking up every
morning loving what you do and then you
have this process of you know you're
you're identifying people and you said
teachers mentors and advisers and you're
you're identifying the people that are
smarter than you so you have to have
this hefty dose of humility yep and the
original title of this chapter was be
humble yes I love that yeah yeah I was
gonna I was gonna ask you where the yeah
the humility is that's perfect so so
when you add in this ft dose of humility
say I know nothing I'm ready to learn
from people that are smarter than me
then you have the guide which we'll get
to about how to get meetings with those
with people like that how to learn from
them optimally and then
then when you're when you're when you're
starting you kind of made this really
powerful example of signal when when you
said that when you're you're getting a
credential from a university as a signal
people are going way beyond credentials
at universities they're doing things
like testing testing your coding ability
is testing your designing abilities
because the credential from the
University is not a very good signal
it's a signal and it's better than
nothing so you need to have some more
than nothing right it's a very blunt
signal it's a blunt signal and sharp
signals come from you having a cheap
things do you have your own website
these are very simple things you have
your own website have do you have asked
us on your website that show that you're
a good developer that you're a good
designer that you're a good interviewer
that you have the skills that you're
trying to get from that from the job
from the profession that you're getting
to and then with I love I love the
process of this of this of this closing
through on a full circle it just it's it
this this you you you see so many people
aiming to find other people you know
when you think of things as a topology
and you think of things as you know
based on clout and then you see who at
the top of the topology are the people
you want to challenge yourself what
they're not going to networking events
yeah you have to find other ways to get
introduced to them and and and maximize
your potential that way and close the
loop I love this opportunity machine and
then in terms of opportunity cost and
time let's go ahead and go to that next
asset yes yeah so whenever you're in a
new stage of your career it doesn't
matter what age you are there is
somebody else who is more experienced
than you at that stage right so this is
a an image actually having the
conclusion to the book where I say you
know this book is something that yes you
can apply at the beginning of your
career but you can really apply at any
stage of your career unless you really
are the best person in the world at what
you do which there's maybe like a few
hundred of those people period you can
reframe your opportunity cost in terms
of what is the new set of skills I need
to learn right so yeah you might be at
Point C where you are much more
experienced than people
points a and B and your time is much
more valuable than theirs at what you do
but if you want to get to point D you
need to figure out what's the difference
in time what's the difference in value
the best mentorships are not gotten
through going to mentoring events the
best mentorships are gotten by finding
very busy people and figuring out what
is it that I can take off their plates
that I will learn from doing but isn't
worth their time that's the difference
here right and I think it's important to
clarify with that even that there's two
types of work that they're too busy to
do there's almost perfunctory work which
this is the work that like an assistant
should do and good assistants want to be
good assistants and they're paid well
for doing that so I'm not degrading that
kind of work but then there's work that
more of a mentee should do this is the
skilled work that can be delegated to a
mentee you need to identify that work
and you don't just go to someone and
tell them maybe your mentee right most
people that will kind of freak out you
want to go to them and you want to say
here are four things that I think I can
do that I think you need done can I do
them and even if you're wrong with these
four things right the fact that you went
out of your way to identify them and
conscientiously put together some kind
of plan to help that person will at
least get that person to talk to you
seriously about it yeah that's a really
good an example for those that are
listening or viewing right now could be
something like for a show like
simulation one could think of it as
someone coming and saying that hey I
know that you're spending some of your
time doing video editing from previous
interviews I know that you're spending
some of your time putting together the
thumbnails and the BIOS for the videos
and you're spending some of your time
trying to categorize the different
professionals that you have in this
network of people that you featured that
you're trying to fundraise money in
order to help sustain and grow the show
let me take those some of those things
off of your plate and then that when you
do that this is something that Mark
Cuban and so many other people have been
saying that they love about people is
when they can come take work off of that
person's plate and then they're like
great here's how love money yes - yeah
because you can know how to do that and
at a certain point as you
do this you gain certain skills and
certain particularly tacit knowledge
that's the kind of knowledge you really
want to learn from a mentor this it
can't be caught taught in a classroom it
can't really be taught in a book it's
taught by being around someone's almost
absorbed by osmosis right as you do that
the cost of replacing you actually
outpaces the cost of of just paying you
so one thing I tell people is like look
I understand not everyone can work for
free but if you can or even if you can
get a job at Starbucks to subsidize your
cost of living and then work for free
with someone you really admire who's on
the up-and-up you will eventually get
paid definitely yeah
yep and then another thing that like
that that's that's that's extreme that's
extremely important point also you when
you illustrate this I just want to also
make it make it clear for people that
what what you can you when you're
viewing this it is slowly like that like
with how much your time is worth depends
on your level of expertise like you like
you said earlier and you can think about
this again as a topology that it's gonna
take you a while to climb up to point D
but when you're at point a you list
these skills that are really important
for you to slowly get to point B C and D
in this field okay and we only get
30,000 days to live a third of them
we're gonna spend sleeping so that gives
us 20,000 days so being vigilant with
our time being vigilant with their
stimuli waking windy like you said when
someone is so vigilant with their time
that they're not taking meetings and
this type of stuff what are they doing
why is it important for you to learn
from them then there's these questions
that are very pressing and that I enjoy
a lot horizontal versus vertical
networking that's the next asset for us
I like this a lot
teach us about this yes so when a lot of
people think about building a network
right they often think about meeting
with peers people that they went to
college with people that they go to grad
school with people that they meet who
are in a very similar stage of career as
them though they may have varied
interests right I first developed this
concept when I was talking to people
about the value
higher education I've come across the
argument quite often where people be
like oh let's help me build a network
it's like well ok but who's in that
network right yeah it's a lot of your
fellow students these are people who
they might be majoring in something
different than you they might be from a
different place in you and that's nice
and you know getting some kind of
diversity and background is is good to
have but when it comes to actually
making that step in your career these
often are not the people who have the
referral power that you need right so
instead what I think is better to think
about for networking as building a
world-class network I don't want to use
the verb networking but building a
world-class network is thinking of a
vertical network so if we think of your
network as an X Y axis right along the x
axis you have your field and interests
right these are your in the center and
as people move along the x-axis they're
in different fields or different
interests finance coding neuroscience
biology right exactly and these are all
collegiate level who these are all your
peers writers twenty-year-olds whatever
right yeah and then in a lot of people I
mean even they go through their whole
careers and this is what their their
network looks like yeah yeah and then
you have on the y-axis the experience
that they have right they're all similar
levels of experience you know you might
have one friend who is in finance and
has an experienced rich uncle or
something right
but that's tends to be an outlier or
something that proves the role right new
exception that proves the rule instead I
think it's important to think about a
vertical network and these aren't
mutually exclusive but if you're
figuring out how you want to spend your
time a vertical network is the network
that has the referral power that you can
get right if think about it this way you
want to get a new job at a company that
you really admire you have a friend who
works as you know an account executive
at that company right relatively junior
employee he can refer you over to a
recruiter at the company or to the VP of
Sales yeah ok that's better than nothing
totally but what if you had a an advisor
or a mentor who was an investor in the
company right or who
is an advisor to the CEO of the company
or is the CEO of the company right and
then they can refer you to the VP of
sales which referral is going to carry
more weight yeah right yeah so the
question becomes when you're thinking
about building a world-class Network
where do I meet these people how do I
get introduced to them how do I contact
them and it's not networking events it's
not by just hoping you bump into them
it's thinking about where do they spend
their time how do they think about their
opportunity costs yes their time is way
too valuable to be going to a networking
event with cheap wine and a bunch of
people looking for jobs right they spend
what little extra time they have
probably doing a handful of things and I
talk about some of these things in the
book but it might be they might be going
to industry conferences right where
they're learning about more maybe
they're even speaking meeting other
highly prominent entrepreneurs right
yeah exactly
I don't want to be part of any club that
would have me as a member right it's
exactly that kind of thing yeah you're
probably not going to meet these people
at an event that's designed for people
at your stage of your career if you do
usually they're volunteering they see
that as kind of a consumption good right
they'll spend their time on leisurely
activities right like what kind of
activities do they enjoy doing I tell
people look it's like you want to meet
experience people who are significantly
more advanced in their careers than you
go to like a fancy wine tasting you're
more likely to find them there right if
you enjoy wine go to a fancy volunteer
at that industry conference at your time
yes that's a huge one exactly I a
significant number of the people my own
network who are people I consider
advisors mentors whatever are people I
met because I was a student volunteer
for nonprofits that held conferences
that's right these people were donors
too right they're our donor galas it
involved in the organizations that they
donate to all right so you want to think
about where are they spending their time
what are their honey pots yeah this this
this example we can we can give in in
for those viewing or listening is when
you're going through let's say like we
were giving an example of you
you're 20 years old maybe you're either
in college or you're in like a coding
school or whatever it might be you're
doing some sort of this this the work
amongst your peers and you're in the
learning process your horizontal network
is all the people that you're in school
in that boot camp etc with then your
vertical network is all of the people
let's say you want to go into into
computer vision or you want to go into
the highest levels of machine learning
you want to really rock it yourself up
in terms of coding let's say well you
want to you want to find the people that
work in those highest departments that
lyft or uber or at Airbnb or Google or
Facebook or these top companies because
if you if you figure out how to message
those people at the tops of the of those
of the vertical at the top of that
topology and you and you're able to
provide them with value which we're
gonna get to right now with these with
these scripts those are the people that
are going to help catalyze your success
they're gonna open up tons of doors for
you opportunities so and this is so much
it's just footwork so much of its just
asking for referrals sending cold emails
and being at the places where these
people will be that's right that's the
three ways you really connect with these
people I love it I love it being where
they'll be sending these emails doing
this footwork to set yourself up Ron
let's pull up the twelfth email scripts
done for you so that's the next the next
axe asset so this is and even even prior
to this we have the actual I want to
pull up the bullet the blue one more
back yeah yeah oh good no no it's all
good
just just this is what you did prior to
this twelve done for you email scripts
and this is available on Zach's web site
yeah it's totally free yep this was
something I put together when I realized
I was like okay if I people coming to me
asking me for career advice I people I
went to college with coming to me asking
me for career advice and so much of this
comes down to referral whether it's
you're running a company you want to get
an investment you want to get hired at a
company you want you're an investor and
you want good investments I was recently
going through our own books from our
first fund and a good number of our best
investments were just referrals right
you
need to meet people right and look I
grew up in like rural Pennsylvania coal
country Pennsylvania I don't come from
having this fancy family network that I
was able to just call on no right a good
chunk of the people I met whether it was
doing business development at practice
or it was while I was in school and
meeting people I meant largely through
sending emails and I did it the wrong
way a lot of the time likewise right
I wrote really bad emails and eventually
I learned okay there's good ways and bad
ways to write these emails I've actually
got a whole course on if you want to
write your own emails you don't want to
lie my scripts here's the psychology of
it but for the core emails that worked
really really well for me I was able to
distill them down for about these 12 and
if you can send enough of these emails
and you can write them well that can be
the thing that you can get underneath
your network with and open it up that's
the leverage point for a lot of people
and this one really comes down to just
can you write the email and can you send
it it doesn't come down to any
privileged background it doesn't come
down to who you happen to know how do
you move that variable I want I want to
show an idea of of this really quick I
have I have here and Ronnie if you can
pull this up that'd be awesome
it's on NDI right now do you see it yeah
so I just have this example and the this
is me emailing a youkai ciao
right and this is me wanting to get in
touch with them original creator on some
really interesting gamification
frameworks and stuff like that youkai
love your work I host simulation in
downtown SF a show featuring the
greatest minds of our time there's a lot
of cool synergy to explore between our
networks and visions we'd love to host
you on the program in april/may if
you're interested send me some dates and
times Alan like very quick to the points
explaining how I'm interested in their
work already and giving him a reason to
reply which is it he'll be on your show
he'll be on the show there's a value add
for the person that I'm a messaging
these and like you can see right below
you know sounds interesting my colleague
right down there you know Bruna is gonna
get in touch and set this up so this is
this is what I would what I would say is
one of the potentially best ways to do
vertical networking is these very short
two to three sentence at most emails
that have the value proposition they
show sincere love for the person that
you've already done research on them and
that and that you're trying to bring
them value and we have examples too of
of what of your of your scripts as well
this one the first asset after the book
this one this is how to set up meetings
how to get meetings and you kind of you
know outline some of these points as
well right and I'll say too i shorter
tends to be better than longer yeah but
most important is that the email is
clear compelling and easy to reply to so
your your email here was a great example
it was clear who are you what do you do
right it was compelling why should I
talk to you and it was easy to reply to
right if you get those three elements it
really doesn't matter how long it is so
long as it's clear compelling and easy
to reply to them I love that so far how
many emails are just hard to reply to
are to reply to yeah if you tell
somebody something like you know let me
know what you think that's a really hard
way to reply to an email
you say would you be interested that's a
yes/no question yeah right
or here are three times I'm available
that's an easy thing to reply to but so
many people they leave their emails up
and ended or I'll see emails whether
they're ones that people send me or that
there's ones that my students send me
they have no ask it's like okay I know I
know what you're trying to get out here
so I'm gonna reply to you but don't be
surprised if people don't reply to you
because it's these are busy people you
get seven seconds of their attention
that's right that's right at most make
it easy for them to reply that's right
and and this is this get a phone call or
meeting with a very busy person this is
the first one of your first first
example in in 212 and these scripts are
so powerful and the way that you explain
them is very powerful and I want to I
want to make it clear that you know this
is again this is when you get higher and
higher up on the topology of influence
and clout the people are guarding and
guarding their time with more and more
vigilance so then for you to be able to
make an ask vehicle to do this vertical
networking is so so crucial and then
let's get let's go to the script we're
on e the next one okay and then here's
where I really love what you know your I
know you one of the one of my main
things about this I love so much is that
in the center part where you say some
point of rapport that's such an easy
thing and it's the sincere tiny drop of
sincere rapport that you've already done
some research on them that you already
know and you're very interested in what
they do and it's so important that it
actually be sincere yes I have a couple
blog posts on my site where I will take
what is clearly spam I have to be
careful about saying this because anyone
can email me I will not make fun of your
email if you send me an email that's not
really well-written but if you're
spamming me like it's big part corporate
spam I will make fun of your email
publicly so I say that because if
someone wants to email me please do
email me see slavek at gmail.com i will
not make fun of you if you send it for
you no but if you're spamming me like a
corporate spammer I will make fun of you
so somebody emailed me last year you're
like
hi Zack big fan of your work in the
crypto space yada yada yada yada I'm
like I've done nothing in the crypto
space that's clearly a BS complement so
you want to make sure that the
compliment you're sending somebody is
actually sincere about their work right
one of my friends is a podcaster in
Pittsburgh named Aaron Watson and I've
had him send me his best cold email
request that he's gotten for someone to
be on his show and I tear this down on
my website I've got this as an example
somewhere and one of the things that the
person who emailed him did was they
talked about how much they loved a
recent episode of his show but it wasn't
the most recent episode it was several
episodes back which means that they
actually had to go and dig through the
show and find an episode that's right
and if somebody came to you Alan and
said I I love this episode with Michael
strong which was a couple weeks ago
right that shows them that shows you hey
they've actually been paying attention
absolutely not that they're just looking
at the most recent one finding something
that they can say I like this right yep
you know that's important that's really
sincere with people people can smell bs
that's right that's right this is such a
beautifully illustrated point about
rapport and you're gonna get right to
people's hearts bye-bye but going
through the practice of falling on your
face a lot that can't be that can't be
fearful you use this term stress-free
email not only do you want to use
shortcuts like Zacks lay back has
provided but also you want to go through
the process of of being fearless if you
want to reach to up the vertical network
you have to be fearless what's the worst
that's going to happen if you email this
person who you really admire they might
ignore you that's the worst that's
really the worst and you had this great
example of a tweet that was sent out
it's like when you email me and you
don't hear back from me it's one of two
things either I I don't I didn't want to
reply to you I read it and didn't reply
it or just got buried and I didn't even
see it
and when most often it's the second
correct and so then reaching out again
in a month or two is actually a great
idea and so this is other thing it's
just a classic Wayne Gretzky quote you
miss 100% sm life you don't take so to
take these shots up the vertical network
and to take lots and lots of shots with
short concise emails is one of the best
things you can do it's one of these
things that is called an asymmetric risk
right like the downsides essentially
nothing yes the upside is huge that's
right that's right massive asymmetric
risk now
all right let's let's um let's talk
about social capital in general I
actually heard this phrase from a
schoolteacher in San Francisco we're
both getting our haircuts and he goes
I'm financially poor but socially
wealthy and I'm like interesting so are
we and I'm like that's a cool way of
phrasing it because social capital
social wealth is actually hugely
financially wealthy - but it's kind of
it's it's it's you have an interested
there's like an interest that's growing
on it to become wealthy it's compounding
over time but it's gonna take a while
for that so to build that when you're 20
that social capital when you're 20 then
your late 20s early 30s is gonna help
you a lot with those next 30 when
somebody asks you know how do I build a
company without raising venture capital
right first of all I tell them great you
should try to do that as long as you can
I I joke with people I'm the most anti
venture capital person who works in
venture capital and teach us why for you
as a founder you should try to own as
much as your company as long as you can
until it makes sense to really put
rocket fuel on the company right if you
put rocket fuel on too early it can blow
up right and I think it's really
important to the more traction you can
get the more of the company you can own
the better price point you can raise
that there's all these factors that go
into it and if you want to build a
company without raising a lot of money
right one of the best ways you do that
is you raise social capital in advance
right instead of raising financial
capital you raise social capital
interests you get people who are more
than happy to do favors for you right
you're you get people who they like you
they trust you you've done
something for them not in this
transactional way of like you owe me now
but in the sense of hey you know Alan
somebody that I really like I really
trust I'm gonna do an introduction for
you to this person who has tons of
gatekeepers it's impossible to get to
right or hey I have a friend who they
have all this extra equipment you could
use I bet I can get it for you for like
a really huge discount right that is
social capital every time you follow
through on your word every time you go
above and beyond you these
supererogatory acts you put you make a
deposit in this bank account yeah yeah
yep and there's there's there's a very I
think important way you start listing
these options intro people to who should
know each other help with an extra set
of hands on pickup value that's being
left on the floor
at the same time I want to I want to
make it really clear that there's other
shortcuts that are really cool to
leverage one of them I think is to not
use social media to the extent that a
vast majority of people are using it as
in I would recommend deleting social
apps from your phone
so keeping Twitter Instagram Facebook
LinkedIn all off snapchat off your phone
one of my friends is a Twitter celebrity
I guess named ed Lattimore it's a great
follow if you're on Twitter he's just at
Lattimore but he's got a tweet that I
actually have in the book that I think
is put very very well he says you know
Twitter is a drug and I am the dealer I
am NOT the user and you want to view
every if your going to be on social
media view it that way these are massive
companies that employ dozens if not
hundreds of PhDs who are paid very very
well purely to destroy your attention
purely to take time from you you will
not beat them yeah and if you're going
to use social media use it in a very
clear way that builds your brand that
helps you create the value and signal
the value that you can create for your
career that's right yeah it's literally
a psychometric profiles that are
super well built out a quantum computing
strength that's pointed at your
attention you're not going to win you're
not gonna win unless you come in with a
really strong mentality of the building
my brand my personal brand and and
that's that's that's one of the ways
another one of the ways I think to do
these shortcuts is to enable oneself the
creative space that they need to breathe
to really sink into their own essence
because when we're so on our devices all
the time
thinking that we're doing productive
things but when we turn them off and we
sit in sit down or lay down and just be
sometimes the creative thoughts and this
is famous I mean hindsight Tesla so many
people were quoted talking about the
importance of just being and letting
creative thoughts arise Cal Newport has
a lot of really good work on this he's a
recent book called digital minimalism
then it's just everyone pick up if
they're interested in all what you're
saying he suggests take a 30-day fast
from social media and then figure out
which elements you need to work back in
right yeah it's like for me for example
I am on Facebook because I am all over
the country all the time I the teams
that I work with are distributed so it's
like it's good to be on it for me to be
able to Facebook message people but I've
deleted my entire newsfeed right yeah
new CD Eradicator you know I've gone
I've gone above that I've unfollowed
literally everyone I am friends with I
found a script that allowed me to do
that so on any device I'm on the
newsfeed is eradicated yeah right it's
great here so Cal Newports book digital
minimalism is good with that and then
deep work is a good theoretical book on
you know what you're talking about right
here that ability to make these creative
connections you need the ability to
focus so even in the execute chapter yes
I mentioned Paul Graham's got this great
essay maker schedule versus manager
schedules right and if you are a maker
of any kind your writer your speaker
your coder
whatever you are you need to have large
chunks of uninterrupted time to really
get into the flow of
things you can't allow social media you
can't allow meetings you can't a lot of
phone calls to interrupt you that's
right that's right
phone on silent phone powered off all
notifications off is another really
powerful one don't get reeled in by the
notifications focus long periods of
focus okay Zach I want to ask you a
couple questions on the way out one of
the questions that I want to ask you is
you know going into the exponential
technology age what are if not the best
most important skill for a young child
to learn the ability to talk with other
people I I think that we're still quite
a while off from really being able to
create technology that passes a Turing
test for face-to-face communication
right humans are weird
humans are hard if you are capable of
talking to other people too it's what I
call a high leverage skill yes Cody
Mills another one of these things right
where it opens up other doors for you to
learn what are like lower leverage
skills that are harder more tactical
skills right so you need to make a
career transition when you're 25 into a
totally new career or when you're 55
your ability to talk to other people to
build relationships with them to put
yourself slightly outside of your
comfort zone is going to open up those
doors for you to actually pursue those
those specific skills and sales is one
of the best ways to teach this and
building emotional intelligence to know
how to and meditation to like deeply
look at someone else's eyes and think
about their entire life journey how they
got there asking questions these these
things about EQ just drive rapport and
relationships do whole new levels I
suggest that everybody get some sales
job at some point in their career yeah
yeah yeah I love it that's a great
answer all right in the simulation
questions we like to ask on the way out
Zach are we alone in the cosmos
I honestly don't know I like to think
that if we are that we are at just the
very very beginning of a an epic story
mm-hmm I think it's it's - it'd be such
a boring story if we are alone and this
is what it looks like right I like the
the idea of a human civilization that
spans the cosmos yeah you know the
beginning of the epic story I love it
and then next question is are we in a
simulation this is like so I was a
philosophy major and I always found the
freewill debates in metaphysics to be
rather boring personally because it
doesn't matter one way or another if we
are because I'm going to act the same
way regardless I'm going to live as if
we're not in a simulation right I'm
going to act as if I do have free will
even if I don't actually have free will
I want to live in a world where I
believe everyone has free will then
people can take responsibility for their
actions they can take responsibility for
their lives a world where we don't have
free will or a world where we live in a
simulation where free will is limited is
a world where it's easier for people to
get by with their excuses and that's not
a world I want to live in mm-hmm and the
last question we like to ask on our show
is what is the most beautiful thing in
the world
I've only been a few experiences in my
life where I've been able to identify
with the word sublime like like almost
tear-inducing Beauty yeah one of the
ones that has popped up a couple times
for me and I think sublimity doesn't
have to be visual it can be auditory as
well there's something about maybe this
is because I was raised by an airline
pilot I don't know there's something
about coming through the early morning
cloud cover and seeing the Sun rising in
the distance like 7 a.m. out of a rainy
City and you get through the rain you
get through the thunder clouds you get
through the storm and you get above that
10,000 foot cloud cover and you can see
the Sun on the horizon there's one of
those moments where I'm like wow I am
sitting on any chair traveling hundreds
of miles per hour going to the other
side of the country in the situation
that would normally have killed my
ancestors from like dysentery if not
dysentery than like being murdered by
other people this is pretty great
yeah I I the whole the the picture
itself is beautiful yes but like the
whole context stuff I don't know I
really like human ingenuity yeah as
awful as airports are as awful as modern
airlines are there's something about
aviation that just still gets it for me
yeah so it's a hard question that was a
good question well answered this has
been such a solid show super
enlightening yeah thank you for having
me this has been a ton of fun thanks for
coming on sags a huge huge pleasure and
when will we be able to have how to get
ahead in our in our hands if everything
goes to plan right now it should be out
the end of the first week of June you
can pre-order it on Amazon great also if
you hop on my email list I am going to
be offering some free order bonuses like
I said I've got some courses that I've
built out sweet so access to those so
things like that beautiful and that's
Zach slaybeck comm that link is in the
bio everyone
also follow Zach on Twitter that link is
in the bio get ready for how to get
ahead go and share more of these stories
about horizontal versus vertical
networking these email scripts how to
get build up your network build up this
world-class network and go and achieve
your actualization share your thoughts
in the comments below share these
thoughts with your communities families
co-workers and you shout out to Ron
Vargas thank you so much for producing
and directing we love you very much and
go and build the future everyone support
the artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in simulations links are below
we need your help in growing and
manifest your dreams everyone
life is short get it done we love you
very much thanks for tuning in peace
[Music]
[Music]